we have this from the postal money we
have a lot of post mail tonight huh
former Ukrainian prosecutor my story
Victor shoken confirms he was fired
after Joe Biden demanded it now a couple
years ago there was a sworn affidavit
from Victor shulkin where he attested to
just this but now we have him giving a a
public statement on this where he spoke
to Fox News and yeah right said uh yeah
so that's your story Libby watch tell us
what happened Yeah so basically Victor
shoken went on with Brett Bear and he
confirmed that he was told when he got
fired that it was Joe Biden's wish that
he'd be fired let's slow down real quick
there may be a lot of people who have no
idea who this guy is do you want me to
do like a hole Yeah I think I'll just
give you the general the general gist
and then you can take it away yeah
Joe Biden flew to Ukraine said I will
illegally withhold a he didn't say
illegally he said I will withhold the
aid a billion dollars unless you fire a
prosecutor this is the the Crux of the
whole argument either against Trump
demanding his impeachment or against Joe
Biden for being corrupt Victor shulkin
is the guy who got fired he is saying he
got fired because Joe Biden demanded it
and and Joe Biden likely took bribes
anyway yeah so I was going to look up
the story but I'm just going to go from
memory because my Google isn't working
you definitely remember all the details
um yeah so basically Victor shoken was a
prosecutor who was investigating barisma
he was investigating barisma because he
was concerned that they were doing
illegal energy deals and who was brisma
purisma is a Ukrainian Energy company on
Whose Board Hunter Biden sat he was
getting 83 000 a month uh his business
partner Devin Archer was also on the
board they were getting this money they
don't have any expertise in energy
burisma was interested in entering the
U.S market they were under investigation
in Ukraine which makes it tough to enter
a U.S market at that point because
you're already looked at as kind of 80.
so basically what happened was the CEO
of burisma signed on Hunter Biden and
Devin Archer to help them with the the
U.S market slash get influence through
then VP Joe Biden so Joe Biden knew the
burisma guys there were meetings with
you know he met them
um he ended up on phone calls with them
at these meetings uh Victor shoken was
the prosecutor tasked with investigating
that Joe Biden
um was the White House
um
he was the guy for the White House
overseeing Ukraine during the Obama
Administration so there had been a
billion dollars in loan guarantees that
were approved uh for Ukraine
Joe Biden was meant to go to Ukraine
deliver the loan guarantees he said I'm
going to withhold this money unless you
fire shoken he said this to Petro
poroshenko who was uh zielinski's
predecessor so he said this poroshenko
was like uh oh okay shoken is totally
fired now and we'll take the money Joe
Biden then went on a panel it was
televised and he bragged about this he
told this story just as eloquently as he
told that Corn Pop leg hair story uh he
went on he's not hiding anything no he
was very proud of what he had done
claiming that shoken was corrupt and
that they got their own guy in there so
okay that is a thing that happened then
Donald Trump in uh July 2019 Joe Biden
had announced her presidency in April of
that year Donald Trump makes a phone
call to then you know president
zielinski who had replaced poroshenko
and he says Hey we've got this money
coming for you I think it was 391
million dollars way less than a billion
by the way uh we have this money coming
for you uh Congress has approved it
that's cool but also I'm interested to
know uh what impact Joe Biden had on the
firing of Victor shoken
um was he involved you know let's sort
of hash that out uh that phone call was
recorded it was leaked the transcript of
that was leaked and then in um you know
the the media had a field day with it
Donald Trump is withholding funds from
Ukraine unless they investigate Joe
Biden so then Congress brings him up on
impeachment charges claiming that he had
withheld funds for his own personal gain
that he had uh committed election
interference by asking Ukraine to
publicly investigate Joe Biden over the
firing of shoken which Biden had already
said he'd done they accused him and
impeached him of election interference
months and months and months before the
election so they said okay Trump you're
impeached because you asked for an
investigation into Biden for something
that he publicly said that he did and
you wanted more details now he's being
prosecuted for all of this stuff
um
and that's not being considered election
interference I was going to say if only
he had ordered uh prosecutors to
prosecute Joe Biden right and have the
the trial date start right before super
Tuesday then it would not be election
interference so that's what they that's
what they impeached him over and if you
read the impeachment documents which I
did yesterday it's very detailed about
how uh Trump was wrong to launch an
investigation into a political opponent
during an election year yeah well I mean
come on to be fair I don't think you
guys have actually read any of the laws
that they're using to to go after Trump
on for the you know when they impeached
him it clearly states that in uh in the
instance that the accused is Republican
the full force of the law shall be you
know levied against this individual
however if said accused as Democrat then
just forget about it Sabrina that's
actually in the law it's okay when we do
it progressives 36-16 or whatever
exactly all of this and more at Tim Cass
you which is going to be launching later
this year
yes yes exactly I am a doctor yes and we
declared it publicly tonight I never
said the universe that was actually
something I should say a long time ago
uh I would be happy to accredit this I'm
willingness into existence I had a PhD
from the University so I could I think
we just made the board all right I would
make the point of circular accreditation
right you get accredited from the
University and then found it so that it
I like it correct so I like this to
explain to people I've been explaining
people credentialism for a long time so
you know I'd be talking to these like a
lot of friends everyone's like you have
to go to college if you want to get a
good job I'll go please and then I'd be
like well I have I have a masters they'd
be like you have a masters I'm like yeah
in nuclear engineering they're like what
do you really need to be like oh yeah
you know from Milton you and they'd be
like what about this right yeah I made
it up it's not an accredited school or
anything but I gave it to myself I used
to want to make up wait a minute College
sweatshirts and be like no this is where
I went to school just like I want to
wear this okay I'll make you some some
some some some uh body at some
organization determines that you are
worthy and gives you a title I can give
myself whatever title I want that's like
with Jordan Peterson being uh
re-educated re-educated by the Ontario
College of Physicians because he made
some incendiary social media posts the
people who complained about Jordan
Peterson and got him investigated and
subject to re-education they were not
his clients they were not his students
they were not his patients or whatever
they were people who saw his posts on
the internet and didn't like them and
didn't like them oh that's pretty
serious that's pretty serious precisely
is supposed to re-educate him the
Ontario College of physicians in fact
there are people that they have said
will be the ones doing the re-education
Jordan Peterson will be paying for it
and those Specialists those experts
those credentialed people cost 225 an
hour Prager you should give out phds if
it doesn't work Jordan Peterson has said
that he's going to put it all on YouTube
well that's like live streaming yeah it
can help offset the cost that he has to
cover which I'm sure they'll make much
more than 220. it'll be great they're
going to make it a minimum
and I was like yeah yeah well and the
the credentialed experts are the ones
who get to decide how long the training
will go so if they feel it's not working
they can do extensions extend it exactly
that they are getting paid to do and
that will be streamed on YouTube so
they've given him essentially they've
given him a
uh almost unlimited fine yeah or or are
fine with no upper limit it's either
that or they take his license and it
goes until he admits I agree with what
you think you know what because leaves
and credentials second one I agree yeah
like as soon as they say it'd be like
you're right absolutely okay great like
we don't think great to see you we don't
think you do agree he's like no no I
totally agree he would say something
else I agree yeah I don't think he'd
ever do that I don't know I think
Peterson's going to be alive screw off
your dang marxists but it wouldn't be
funny if he's like no I already minded
no like yeah he's gonna argue with them
yeah for sure he's gonna put it on
YouTube it's gonna be hilarious he's
gonna wear what if he changes their mind
live
what if he under educate or well so it's
funny
under educated have you guys you've
heard about like the FBI agents who were
tasked with monitoring right-wing
message boards started becoming right
wing I totally believe it yeah they're
like they're seeing all these posts and
then they're going like wait a minute I
told this stuff I was wrong and I wasn't
supposed to talk about it but when I
read through it they're making some good
oh a good points my goal is to get my
NSA mind for there to be churn in the
NSA because they keep having to assign
new people to me because they go
oh no yeah oh he's right crap he's right
and then they have to quit or whatever
maybe they'll just you know smash no
what happened what happens is is like
the uh the NSA has a they know that the
assignment to spike is like a three
month rotation and so they tell they
tell the agent like it's a three-month
rotation just so you know like watch
three months like typically we do two
years like just trust us and then after
like two and a half months the guy's
sitting there and he's like shaking he's
got a cigarette and he's going back and
forth he's right about everything man
he's right about everything and they're
like all right time to get him out of
there we all have to go like through
mandatory meetings with the psychologist
afterwards who's like no no I'm not a
doctor
they have to put him through the
re-education program yeah they have to
put them through Jordan that's these
people are good that are going to be
doing Jordan Peterson they're the ones
that have to deprogram the my NSA
minders into like re-believing they have
to re-blue pill them
I always thought that was weird about
like phds like you have to go defend
your thesis but what if I don't respect
anyone who's on the panel what if I
don't like any of their these I'm
questioning your Authority yeah I don't
understand I've always found it weird
the credentialism and the people
insisting that they're a doctor and so
forth because I was proud to tell people
I barely made it out of high school like
I didn't go to college and I had
multiple successful businesses and you
know a great life my wife's like super
hot and everything and I'm like you know
like why why would I I like being able
to say that I got this despite the fact
that the schooling system tried to keep
me down hard work is hard that's why
it's called hard work right thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time